brandi love you brought the story up to
me yesterday i don't know who brandy
love is but apparently bradley love is
uh one of your heroes just put me on
front street yeah
gerard uh very popular i can't grab
gerard's phone it's risky
if i grab one i have to be very careful
when i take gerard's phone
he snaps it out of my hands if i have
it's one of my hats
so conservative porn star brandy love 48
is kicked out of florida's republican
conference for high school kids because
outraged parents complained daily mail
brandy love48 attended the student
action summit with turning point usa in
tampa
florida saturday and post for photos in
front of exhibits and a saving america
tour bus love initially arrived at tampa
convention center as an enthusiastic vip
guest but was
suddenly kicked out for backlash against
christian organizers christian
conservatives immediately began
criticizing her attendance on social
media slamming her organization's
decision to allow an adult film star to
attend an event
targeted at 15 and 16 year olds she is
capitalizing on the attention
by selling t-shirts poking fun at one of
the conference's founders she's selling
shirts with the slogan i trigger charlie
kirk
on her only fan's website so what are
your thoughts about this dude this is
the reason i didn't grow up a republican
well one of the wild things over the
course of the last 15
20 years for anybody that's been paying
attention to the political leanings of
america
has been watching when we were kids the
christian conservative of my youth was
the karen
the christian conservative was the
person that was judgmental
telling you what you couldn't do they
were the the the the arbit the
self-appointed arbiters of the zeitgeist
you can't do this we can't have that we
can't show these people holding hands on
tv
put the beds apart blah blah blah then
somewhere it shifted to this progressive
left became the woke left became the new
arbiters of the zeitgeist and what's
what's acceptable in a civilized society
and
and the ivy it kind of comes from the
ivy leagues when the ivy league switch
from william f buckley to
to uh you know aoc this this kind of
like this
was a legend they think they control
us and like what we can and can't think
and what we can and can't do and this
bothers me to no end
because it's exactly what you said if
i'm leaving
if i'm leaving my home because the
policies are so bad right there i'm
open-minded to a new idea
and then immediately i go and i and i
come to a new community this is a
community event
and the first thing they say is you're
not good enough to be here you're not
perfect get out
i'm like screw these guys man absolutely
screw these guys
also if the idea is that the you know we
don't want to corrupt the minds of the
christian youth what was mary magdalene
dude what was mary magdalene's job
jesus himself took on who let me ask you
a question kai pull up swimsuit to
cover uh did you see the swimsuit
edition that just came out the sports
illustrated
did you see this that's the sports
uh annual swimsuit cover
transgender elena bloom wow okay
first transgender to be covered you
think that's okay
what do you think gerard i'm actually
curious
i think i don't stand a chance in miami
i got to stop drinking boy that's what i
think this is
[Laughter]
transgender that is unbelievable i would
never have guessed that in a million
years but
i'm asking you gerard are you okay with
that yeah i got no problem let people
live their life man what i don't like
specifically in the media is if if
they're promoting her
specifically because she's a transgender
i have an issue with that
i i want to live in a meritocracy as
much as possible okay
um but look she's beautiful
what i mean she's there's no way to say
she's not beautiful right i mean
we don't know how what photoshop is
doing there's no there's i don't know
man but
come on that's that's a swimsuit model
okay i mean it is what it is
so so for you this you're totally fine
with
i have no issue what do you think about
this i mean if you if you know the
sports illustrated swimsuit issue that's
what you get
so i'm not offended by it at all now
miss nevada i feel
bad for the naturally born women that
they lost
to a naturally born man who converted
mostly because
i think pulled that story up i think
what you're doing is you're telling and
i just think that the image that you're
giving to young women is that you're not
good enough the way that you are
this other person got thousands of
dollars worth of surgery to make
themselves
the ideal candidate for miss nevada for
the
like like actually completely redid
their body
to be the perfect candidate for the
pageant system and i think that that's a
really
dangerous message so let me tell you
where i'm going with this gerard one day
when you have kids we'll talk and i'm
actually curious to know what position
you're going to take so for me
i i understand the and i responded to
her and i sent out a tweet i never got
back
anything from her i don't think she
wanted to go that route and have that
conversation with me because
this is an event for 15 to 16 year olds
okay
that's a targeted event for 15 to 16
year olds
i don't care if you're a porn star or
anything
if it's 15 to 16 year olds it's not your
place to go
number one you're trying to create noise
which more power to you now if turning
point usa
is doing an event that's 24 year olds 30
year olds whatever and she goes and they
turn him down
now that's a different story right there
if you're losing that you're 15 16 year
old
do i uh am i okay with somebody going in
their ware well just to be clear that's
kind of forgiving me but
was this a teen only event could you
only get tickets if you were
understanding if this story here is
saying 15 to 16 year olds i'm just
simply
sharing what this thing was a
conservative christian version of social
media
decision forms targeted at 15 and 16
year olds but this is but that doesn't
mean exclusive too
if if it is what i'm saying to you is if
it is an event for
teenagers i can see why that concerned
them if it is
if it is an event where that's the
teenagers i can see why parents
i can see why a parent may say i don't
want her to be there okay
like just like for me to say hey i'm a
conservative drug dealer i'm just going
to be here listen i'm trying to vote for
mega
i'm on trump but i'm a conservative
director so if jay-z
was there who admitted
a 20-year career selling crack before is
he doing it right now
no so so her job precludes her from her
ability to
if it's right now yes why if jenna
jameson comes and you were doing it in
the past it's what i did in the past
it's a different story
what if she's not repentant about what
she did in her past like i mean that's
here here's the thing about that what if
she's not repentant like she said she
does something she passed i made a
couple million dollars
you're forgiven totally fine but but i'm
not asking for forgiveness i did my job
as my job but there is but as a
parent i'm just giving you the optics of
the parent the parents gonna be worried
about the fact that
here's a person around my kids that
could influence my kids to think
this is okay i don't want that i'm going
to be putting 80
pressure as parents are going to say hey
you guys got to make sure she's not here
because i don't want my kids to be
thinking about that okay so let me give
you some pushback on that if that's the
case if that's the way you personally
feel why wouldn't you retract
your kid from the situation why would
you infringe upon somebody else's rights
to be there if she wasn't doing anything
salacious
but but the target of the audience was
for teenagers the audience that was
being targeted for that
is teenager so i i i don't know how to
explain this for
from my perspective i don't care if
you're a
former porn star it does nothing to me
if that's what you chose to do with your
body
more power to you if that's what you
chose which to do with your body but if
you're going to a place
publicity stunned to kind of drive more
attention with kids and teenagers in
today's time
i don't know man i think it's a little
bit of a touchy subject on what you're
doing i i
you know the fact i'm with you the fact
that this was geared towards kids she
had no business being there because
a she's not known for her conservative
beliefs you're not hiring her as a guest
speaker or anything
she is there to sell porn and sell her
image and sell
sex and those kids are too
impressionable at that age there's no
reason for her to be there
by the way now let me give you a
completely different side of the side of
the story pamela anderson when you think
about it what do you think about it
baywatch what else do you think you know
just a hot you know chick
tommy tommy you think about the time
i got to be honest i think a little more
about tommy lee a train wreck for 20
years
afterwards i was a kid when that thing
came out and i was like but
we got we got some growing watch what
happens as a human so you and baywatch
you went what a hot uh yeah just a
20-year train wreck and just
pop culture okay and then you said what
tommy lee right okay so now check this
out
is she somebody that you look at as an
example for
young women and teenage boys is that
someone's like oh my gosh you would be
such a great
no that's not the first thing i would
think about okay but let me tell you how
much of an
example she is on why i think she is
very necessary in today's society
she comes out and she teaches her sons
about porn
and here's what she says she says listen
she tells her sons
i would go on dates with men and when it
would come down to having sex
these guys would start hitting me
slapping me doing all this stuff to me
like what are you doing this doesn't
feel good
so then i would say to my sons don't let
porn fool you
that's a movie that doesn't feel good
with everybody and not everybody
likes this you have to understand it so
she spoke to her sons about porn
and how to not get this misconception
about her porn is right okay
so is she fully qualified to share that
message with the people to see it
i think she's qualified qualified i
think she's very qualified she's an
authority on the matter
she is an absolute authority but guess
what i see with that i think that
if i'm putting an event together i don't
mind if that if somebody like that comes
and gives a message to young boys
yeah there's a there's a motive behind
it that's a positive motive
versus i go to this girl's twitter
account and i just kind of see what
she's doing
brandy love extremely attractive i'm
sure there's a big market for her
and then the next tweet is hey this is
the shower i'm going to be showering out
of today and here's the view
so to me if it was exclusive to i i
don't know enough about it
i don't either i'm telling you right now
it's exclusive to kids and she got it
under false pretense i i'll
i'll back off for sure but if it was
open to the public and they were just
marketing it to younger kids if it was
like a disney thing where it's open to
everybody but we're marketing
but still that's just as bad because
because
if you're marketing it to kids then
you're bringing in a whole generation of
kids that should not be exposed to porn
at that point
other jobs should not be allowed by the
way by the way i put that on turning
point usa and let me tell you why
you tell me a club like back in the days
there was a club called carnival
in l.a carnival was 14 and up you
shouldn't have a club that's 14 and up
so by
that was 14 and up yeah are you out of
your flipping minds my father would
never
ever ever ever ever let us go to this
club i was 16 years old
cabaret 12 year old who how did this
pass the zone
here's the how do you bring that to the
board here's the point though you're 16
year old years old you go there yeah
who's the market and i'm 16 i'm tall so
i don't look 16.
i probably look 22 i mean i've looked 40
since i was 16 anyway so it's not like
it takes you
back so you go there next thing you know
and by the way okay carnival this club
you know what it had
it had you know how you have the booth
with the couch and all that stuff
they had rope they had what do you call
it drapes to cover it up oh
fantastic and without pay you didn't
have to it wasn't bottle service right
yeah
i'm playing 15 16 years old i'm going
over here and
you're like okay yeah so so the point is
that's where
you know how long that club lasted not a
long time sponsored by wayfair
meaning the point is turning point usa
has to learn from this to know if you're
saying
under 18 you have to keep it under i
need to know what's what else though
like i mean would would you have an
issue with jay-z being there
no no no look
porn is dangerous and you do not expose
that to 15 or 16. so that's just alone
started in porn
would you have a problem with him come
on nobody knows that nobody knows that
you don't think he's doing it so the
issue is that she is right now at this
moment
a porn star damn right what if somebody
was a was a weed entrepreneur should
they be should be there
should not should not be there no this
even if it's illegal
yeah i'm telling you he should not be
there so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you